it hit me the other day we're gonna be
getting sequels to all of the kion
franchises Bill and Ted John wick and
the matrix but when are we gonna get
that devil's advocate sequel we're gonna
watch the cyberpunk 2077 official story
trailer talk about that briefly and then
we will go into the great Braden's
gameplay yeah
[Music]
born leader we need to only give this
desk only strings don't know
it's like a rock star
yeah
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
Cary's better be at this game like so
much better be one of the like leads or
a playable character because the way
they're teasing him like he's barely in
it it's getting kind of concerned
I mean what's great about that is the
fact that when this game was first being
teased and introduced it wasn't like
Keanu Reeves was on display already
excited for this game before we knew
Keanu Reeves is gonna be in it or at
least before there was an official
trailer with Keanu in it but yeah I mean
now that we know that he better beyond
just being the moments we saw in the
trailer
you know what I find so refreshing about
this trailer yeah we've talked plenty
about this game already on this channel
but what I find especially refreshing
about the cyberpunk franchise so far you
know just based off of the marketing for
it while you do get a more tense tease
at the end and a lot of the time the
gameplay Elise you you do get some
intensity and I'm sure this will be
intense at moments the thing that I'm
loving about the marketing for this so
much of the trailers nowadays for things
go for the most like epic heavy dramatic
approach and I love that I really do I
think that's awesome I don't feel like
we get enough of pure adrenaline
pulse-pounding exciting trailers for
video games as much or at least we're
just not covering them that much to get
that with here with this like cyberpunk
world I think is just so refreshing I
love what we're getting with the tease
and what's to come because this does
kind of feel like Grand Theft Auto but
in 2007 in the future the game is not
like doom but the gameplay with the the
kind of speed and go
reminds me of do everything that's
coming out with this just looks like a
blast
yeah and it's just refreshing to get you
know some tribe just the Treasury but
check it out later even the heavier side
so to get some is just like really fun
and the tease of Keanu and that just
sounds awesome yeah and this kind of has
everything because it does certainly
pack that action-packed punch and from
what we've seen in the previous trailers
we've seen more of this sort of you're
on a mission and you're sneaking around
stuff but it really does make it feel
like it's just this whole other world
and more so than ever but especially
watching this trailer I was like I would
love to play this video and really sink
into this world and be able to explore
the open world as well as go on these
missions and stuff and yeah this was a
more intense trailer in terms of just
octane but I feel like that fits
perfectly with the attitude they've been
demonstrating to these characters every
time we've seen footage so far yeah it
really looks like a like a Blade Runner
movie or annelida type movie come to
life that's a really cool and exciting
special thing I think yeah the fact that
you know they do have Keanu and they
have some other recognizable faces in
there makes me wonder who else might
show up in a game like this because
especially this was a good and I knew
that would be maybe a little more
distracting than Keanu Reeves being
there but you know I mean there's so
many actors out there who are like
tailor-made for this kind of world sadr
know just the possibilities seem really
fun and broad and there are five kinds
of pubic hair you can customize alright
guys well let's talk to the gameplay
trailer now
you call me snatch the cash in work is
complete represents the final work John
it's like dreads lawgiver yeah
that person beat that Rubik's Cube solve
the cube before I blow your slow deep
breath your cortisol and adrenaline
spikes but the soft activated your
hormone blockers nothing happened
you're alive and well Wow Ruby I was
raped too much thought I feel the guy's
pain he's dressed is hope hope wrapped
up in something else
but I took a booster just before you'll
be fine got everything set up that's
which over to edit mode
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now our Akuma
okay you can also reset the recording
that'll take you right back to the
beginning
now for some fun this year's why he came
in the first place
analysis mode you get to you and even
scan details of the environment recorded
by the PD focus on the heat the gun this
gun gets from his play at the beginning
not scared
switch to the audio okay now you should
see sound signatures this game trains
you to be an editor seriously like
what's happening to me
[Music]
we'll move on when you get bored
[Music]
like what Edd's got Karoshi objects like
crap in Furman meaning you should be
forward to the artist the editor
throwing this crazy-ass music
must've caught a shooter you'll see in a
sec can feed to the screen behind the
clerk roll back to where the screens and
the kids field of vision then skin oh
that's awesome
cyberpunk magnify meet damn dude
I love that every glimpse we've got of
this game has been like different flavor
has this brought a different layer to
what to expect that is so mind-blowing
yeah in terms of investigation
exploration of what you can do it might
not be like the most trippy
you know like Oh crazy violence or
whatever in terms of options to to
really get involved in be patient cuz
I've gotten really into taking my time
now with when I'm playing a game and
just really exploring every little bit
all those options with like isolating
sound magnifying Clips when he gets shot
I would have loved to have bid that
player to let go all right now how do I
figure out who shot me like that I would
have spent forever on it I would have
had a blast do it oh yeah I actually
loved that
that was so cool yeah it enhances like
the mystery part in the investigative
part and yeah it's a mode that I never
would have thought cuz there have been
games that have dealt into you know
investigation and interrogations and
stuff but to actually have this where
you're solving a puzzle and you're
looking at the evidence around you and
kind of doing the peripherals and stuff
like that it's something I hadn't
expected really well that's super
cyberpunk genre to do that and that's
something I don't think a lot of people
even factored in for what you can do
with this game looks like a scene in
Blade Runner 34 to 46 oh magnified is
punching in Mennonite trope I in
futuristic movies is like kind of
ridiculous how could you possibly be
magnified but there's all this other
crazy a technology already happening in
here and they're explaining it through
like the mechanics behind it Emily
alright I by I believe it
one day the visual enhancement didn't
look super crisp and clear yeah I was
like of all the visual enhancements I've
seen this one's kind of plausible
lacking in the sense that yeah it's
still a bit degraded plus the telephone
that girl's really hot oh yeah well
anybody you're gonna be working with in
a game like this who's female will be
hot oh good like a fantasy girl well
good as long as that's a thing that the
game developers thought of mm-hmm then
we'll be okay oh yeah yeah you can
customize your hotness too I'm sure
Oh guys a character you know when you're
playing your own character that is that
what the option is hot hotter hotter hot
hotter oh it's it's an honest objective
opinion here what is hot if you leave
the game enough times you can get like a
homely skin - oh so we not hot I want so
cool yeah and that adds to your stealth
because people don't like looking at not
hot pee Brian all right guys well
cyberpunk 2077
you're gonna preorder this game let us
know your thoughts in the comments down
below you can subscribe to the real
rejects if you enjoyed our video hit
that like button click that notification
bell last but not least Boston Kelly
fairly new patron eject to our patreon
page thank you so much Austin for
joining learned a little bit about this
gentleman and we have something that's
actually kind of in common he was
telling us about how his grandma
actually introduced into a lot of great
comic books like Batman and flash have
funny enough all my Batman comics that I
first ever got were from my aunt so not
exactly my grandma but she was kind of
like a grandma to me you know you don't
really hear that too often about getting
these comic books from an elder of yours
who's female especially so it's nice to
have that thing in common with you buddy
yeah and also homeboys from Michigan
which is going so cool all over there
and again is the place to be right yeah
if those summer vacation plans good but
I'm glad that you are staying safe I'm
happy to have you here when you turn 21
in a couple months I hope you don't go
to the strip club yeah it will ruin your
life you will end up bankrupt
did you watch hustlers true story for
50% of all males and I have a feeling
you'll land in that category with the
women who are in Michigan yeah so save
your money and go to that comic book
store when it opens yeah yeah blow your
load there mm-hmm all over the comics
seeing buddy